on passe au grand débat de ce club
consacré évidemment à la présidence des
républicains on connaît les deux
finalistes Erik sotti et Bruno
Retailleau s'affront donc le week-end
prochain désir soir ils ont tous deux
envoyés des signaux au troisième homme
Aurélien Pradier Jonathan du prière
[Applaudissements]
la victoire d'Éric Ciotti était
pressentie favori auprès des militants
le député des Alpes-Maritimes arrivent
en tête du premier tour de l'élection
pour la présidentielle avec plus de 42%
des suffrages l'homme tenant d'une ligne
droite IR assumée veut croire que la
victoire est proche ce résultat vient de
tomber il me remplit de joie de
confiance d'espérance pour aborder la
victoire au second tour avec tous ceux
qui m'ont soutenu certains
parlementaires qui le soutiennent
abordent le second tour avec le calme
des vieilles troupes tu as pas de il y a
pas de grandes surprises candidat
sérieux les militants le savent et donc
voilà on est confiant pour la semaine
prochaine mais
le canciotisme et que rien n'est joué le
patron des sénateurs LR Bruno Retailleau
n’entend pas rendre les armes s'il
n'obtient que 34% des suffrages 6000
voix seulement le séparent d'Éric Ciotti
qu'il pense avoir atteint un plafond de
verre pour une Retailleau sur une ligne
conservatrice plus libérale pense encore
pouvoir renverser la table pour moi la
Bonne Nouvelle justement c'est d'avoir
déjoué les productiques alors je peux
même vous faire une confidence ce soir
non seulement tout devient possible les
dimanches gagnent dimanche prochain je
gagnerai pour les soutiens du sénateur
de Vendée Bruno retaillot peut espérer
surfer sur sa dynamique du premier tour
Bruno a fait une très bonne campagne de
premier tour rappelez-vous il y a
quelques semaines de cela voir quelques
jours on nous disait que la campagne
était jouée d'avance que le candidat
Éric Chatti aurait remporté dès le
premier tour cette élection ce n'est pas
le cas tout au contraire je pense que
Bruno a créé une dynamique et cette
dynamique va devoir s'amplifier pour le
second tour encore une fois c'est le
candidat de l'unité du rassemblement du
parti Éric Ciotti ou Bruno Retailleau
pour l'emporter les deux hommes savent
qu'ils auront besoin du troisième
Aurélien Pradier le député LR du Lot
outsider de la compétition se
revendiquant de la droite sociale
réalise avec 22% des voix un score qui
le place mécaniquement en faiseur de roi
courtisé par ces deux adversaires le
jeune loup n'a pas manqué d'ironiser sur
la situation je voudrais remercier enfin
et féliciter mes deux amis et
concurrents erikiotti et Bruno
Retailleau les remercier pour toute
l'attention qu'il me porte désormais
depuis quelques instants les remercier
pour les mots d'encouragement de soutien
presque d'amour qui les expriment depuis
quelques heures à mon égard que l'un et
l'autre sachent que j'y suis extrêmement
sensible une manière de faire monter la
pression sur les deux candidats restant
dans la course pour peser sur le futur
du parti on demandera pas de poste
c'est ça c'est autant de postes qui sont
libres pour les autres on ne demandera
pas de poste mais on va peser dans cette
famille politique qui doit se
reconstruire pour le moment Aurélien
Pradier ménage le suspense autour d'une
éventuelle consigne de vote pour le
second tour le parti et l'IRA
définitivement son nouveau président
dimanche prochain
à ce sujet
[Musique]
moins de 10 points d'écart le sépare de
Bruno taille haut qualifié c'est un
résultat surprise pour vous oui vous
c'est un résultat classique non c'est
pas c'est un peu surprenant mais pas
plus que ça finalement vous savez faut
pas trop s'emballer quand même
70% de 90 milliards qui ont voté
ce ne sont pas les Français ce sont des
adhérents ce sont des militants ce sont
une affaire de militants tout ça
ça dit pas grand chose pour dire la
vérité on s'excite tous là on fait
monter la sauce on est journalistes on
est fait pour ça mais les Français sont
très loin de tout ça vous savez ce qui
est important c'est de savoir quand même
quel est le coût du pays et je suis pas
sûr que le pouls du pays il batte au
rythme de quelques milliers de personnes
qui
[Musique]
essayent de voir qu'est-ce qui peut
différencier monsieur Retailleau Pradier
Ciotti je ne sais pas c'est le match
assez ouvert plus ouvert que vous pouvez
l'imaginer en tous les cas
qu'ericsiothil avait imaginé il y a un
faiseur de roi qui s'appelle Pradier
Aurélien Pradier on va voir on va voir
ce que ça donne son message plein
d'ironiste c'est-à-dire qu'il est
renvoient tous les dos tous les deux dos
à dos sans grande sans grande révérence
on va dire quand même
ça c'est assez intéressant donc on va
voir on va voir c'est assez ouvert le
match est ouvert le match est ouvert
compte tenu du résultat d'hier le match
est ouvert en fait le fait même qui est
un second tour et en soit une surprise
il va entièrement raison c'est pas
du tout important à l'aune de des
problèmes
sur les résultats c'est c'est la
première fois
depuis plus d'une vingtaine d'années que
une élection interne hors primaire je
veux dire un second tour la dernière
fois c'était c'était en 99 quand Michel
le mari était au second tour face à
Jean-Paul Delevoye pour la présidence du
RPR et là donc on a un second tour c'est
déjà soit une actualité
mais là où
comment dire le le second tour ne
réserve pas énormément de surprises
c'est que quand même
eriki avec 43% face au 30 34% de Bruno
Retailleau devrait enfin à l'avantage
arithmétique et par ailleurs il a un
autre avantage et j'imagine comment en
discuter plus plus longuement
c'est que Bruno Retailleau étant plus
conservateur que Éric Ciotti sur le plan
des thèmes de société
cela risque de d'attirer moins
d'électeurs au second tour que qu'Eric
ciotype qui qui sur ces sujets là c'est
toujours montré soit évasif soit un peu
plus progressiste entre guillemets que
son contrat vous parler de la question
de la ligne mais sur le plan
arithmétique est-ce qu'il a un avantage
avec ce type ou est-ce qu'on peut dire
que grosso modo il a fait le même nombre
de voix qu'il a eu à la primaire en
demi-1 décembre 2021 et que c'est une
forme de plafond de verre
ça n'a rien à voir là c'est vraiment un
autre en plus il y a des choses qui vont
peser à mon avis c'est quand même le
soutien et puis la trajectoire d'ici à
la présidentielle
chez Ciotti c'est très clair
avec leur Wauquiez
tout est l'horizon est assez dégagée je
dirais j'ai Retailleau c'est plus c'est
moins c'est moins clair on va on va dire
ça comme ça oui Retailleau et réputé
plus conservateur ça laisse c'est
certainement le cas
bon on va voir il y a des choses qui
peuvent qui peuvent évoluer parce que
Retailleau va peut-être être obligé de
mettre une dose de social dans son
programme qui va être imposé notamment
par Xavier Bertrand
effectivement on le rappelle la ligne en
tout cas d'Aurélien Pradier alors est-ce
qu'elle a été euh alors là c'était
vraiment le gaullisme social il était
contre une réforme des retraites moi je
pense qu'il y a quand même des
incertitudes sur l'orientation des
militants qui ont voté Aurélien Prady
parce que certes et bien Bruno
Retailleau à cette image de conservateur
la droite vendéenne vraiment à cheval
sur les questions sociétales mais en
même temps faut pas oublier qu'il y a
xiiotti c'est celui qui était proche des
idées de eczéma pendant la
présidentielle ça a pu braquer une
partie des militants de droite donc
voilà il y a peut-être une incertitude
est-ce que ces militants vont se
partager dans le vote au second tour
d'autant que cette incertitude elle est
aussi peut-être pour l'instant cultivée
par Olivier qui ne donne pas de
consignes de vote donc mais qui s'est
montré à ses proches de d'Éric ci dans
les derniers jours de la campagne du
premier tour
Aurélien Pradier d'ailleurs comment dire
beaucoup moins d'atomes crochus au plan
personnel avec Bruno Retailleau qu'avec
Eric Ciotti Eric Ciotti qui est donc qui
dirige la mission nationale
d'investiture de LR Aurélien Pradier et
le secrétaire général du parti donc ce
sont deux hommes qui ont beaucoup plus
travaillé ensemble même si Aurélien
Pradier à la réputation d'être un
solitaire professionnellement sur le
plan politique mais il a il a beaucoup
plus travaillé avec avec Eric sotti avec
Bruno Retailleau d'ailleurs il y a aussi
derrière la petite querelle mais alors
là vraiment dans des trucs qui
n'intéressent absolument pas les
Français mais la querelle entre
sénateurs et député pas mal de députés
proches de d'Aurélien Pradier ont d'ores
et déjà dit aux journalistes dont votre
serviteur que ils allaient voter sans
grande hésitation pour
erikioti tout simplement parce qu'il y a
plus de d'atomes crochets
il a intérêt à prendre position je suis
pas sûr qu'il est intérêt à apprendre
position je ne pense pas qu'il en est en
vie je pense qu'il a envie de savourer
son son score encore une fois toute
proportion gardée mais c'est un score
quand même c'est une bonne surprise pour
pour lui ça lui montre ça lui prouve en
tout cas ses yeux que sa stratégie de
d'électr libre un peu gaulliste social
qui s'est droitisé dans les derniers
jours de la campagne à fonctionner et
donc je pense qu'il a tout intérêt à
savourer cela jusqu'au bout
manier l'ambiguïté et faire de lui une
espèce de faiseur de roi même si je
pense qu'on se forment intérieur son
choix est déjà fait votre a pour ce type
il intervient à le rendre public on va
voir non je pense qu'il va faire monter
les enchères il va envoyer des ce qu'on
appelle dans d'autres domaines des
signaux faibles
voilà c'est c'est sûr que il a il a
beaucoup d'humour quand on l'a vu c'est
un garçon qui est assez surprenant
qui a un fort caractère pas simple pas
simple du tout moi je pense qu'il a
bénéficié d'une chose c'est la jeunesse
et je pense qu'il y a énormément de
jeunes qui sans même trop faire
référence parce que c'est vrai que
l'histoire de la retraite par exemple
c'est assez discriminant et on peut dire
que je suis pas sûr qu'à droite ça passe
vraiment bien mais peu importe ce qu'ils
ont touché au départ ils ont voté pour
pour un jeune viens de dire les anciens
on vous a assez vu et dans les dans les
meetings même les mêmes certains
adhérents
âgés ont vu en Pradier un jeune en
capacité de renverser la table ce pas
trop pourquoi comment c'est quelque
chose voilà c'est du ressenti pur là
mais en voyant Pradier c'est quand même
ça saute aux yeux visuellement par
rapport à ce petit et Retailleau c'est
peut-être un juste pour les deux mais
voilà le fait que on a un candidat plus
dynamique plus jeune qu'on n'a pas vu
auparavant qui était inconnu des
déménitents avant que la campagne ne
démarre et dans certains meetings je
j'ai mémoire de certains soutiens même
de scioti qui disait en voyant ce petit
arrivée bon ok c'est le favori mais
certains éléments qui disent
c'est un peu tout ça c'est un peu vieux
quoi c'est un peu et le petit jeune
là-bas il est un peu donc il a profité à
plein de ça et c'est un score assez
prometteur pour lui donc autant qu'il en
profite on va parler de la ligne vous
avez un peu commencé à en parler mais
monsieur mais Alex vous avez regardé les
lignes des deux candidats Eric ce
thibauto vous avez cherché des
différences de lignes de stratégie entre
les deux hommes c'est pas facile hein
et Bruno Retailleau car ils ont quand
même beaucoup de points communs
politiques ils sont partisans d'une
droite ferme sur la sécurité les
migration la laïcité ils sont plutôt
libéraux sur le plan économique mais on
peut quand même noter quelques
différences d'abord deux stratégies de
campagne qui divergent Bruno Retailleau
lui veut rassembler la droite le parti
compris les plus modérées alors qu'avec
ce type joue sur une droite de rupture
écoutez
je te mettrai toute mon énergie pour
assembler notre famille politique qui
sait trop souvent déchiré le
rassemblement c'est pas une option c'est
la condition de notre redressement moi
je revendique d'être de droite je
revendique demain des réformes de
rupture le droit du sang afin du
regroupement familial oui la baisse des
impôts massivement on n'a jamais osé on
a toujours été timoré et bien il faut
lever nos tabous
ensuite il y a une différence de vision
de la société vous le disiez Jules Bruno
Retailleau est plus conservateur il a
une obsession c'est la protection la
conservation de notre civilisation le
mot civilisation il l'utilise à toutes
les sauces que ce soit pour les français
pour les Ukrainiens dont la lutte contre
l'islamisme on va l'écouter ce
qu'attendent de nous nos compatriotes
les Français c'est qu'on défende à la
fois leur niveau de vie les conditions
matérielles de l'existence mais aussi
leur mode de vie tous ces petits signes
de la culture de notre civilisation
cette vaillance là l'Ukraine la tire de
cette fierté nationale ils sont une
grande nation il attire parce que ils
veulent préserver leur culture leur
civilisation moi j'ai souvent dit que la
droite devait porter un projet de
civilisation ben voilà un bel exemple
moi je pense que
l'islamisme c'est un combat culturel
voilà le projet de civilisation c'est
vraiment la ligne de Bruno Retailleau et
en face Erik sotti joue la carte d'une
droite plus en phase avec la société
peut-être plus moderne et d'ailleurs il
avait taclé Bruno Retailleau dans le
débat des trois candidats sur le fait
que la sénatoriale avait rejeté
l'introduction du droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution écoutez avec ce
type
donc la droite ne peut pas être un garde
elle doit être en phase aussi avec la
société je vois qu'au là où on veut nous
emmener soit soyons fiers de ce que nous
avons fait cette droite elle doit être
ouverte sur la société et puis on finit
par une différence de poids entre deux
candidats à la tête d'un parti c'est la
stratégie pour la prochaine
présidentielle vous le disiez avec ce
petit veut et bien désigner Laurent
Wauquiez comme le candidat de la droite
immédiatement enfin très vite en tout
cas après sa nomination à la tête du
parti alors que Bruno Retailleau lui
veut prendre le temps de reconstruire
les idées de la droite et puis ensuite
penser à la présidentielle écoutez
en 2024 on va avoir des élections
européennes j'espère qu'on les gagnera
mais si jamais on trébuche
mais on l'électrocute Laurent ou le
candidat qu'on aura désigné donc je
pense qu'il faut y aller avec précision
le candidat en risquera pas de
l'électrocuté si on a plus d'électricité
voilà si on a plus de jus si on n'est
plus là il risquera plus rien voilà et
ceci c'est très clair c'est Laurent
Wauquiez en 2027 Bruno Retailleau est un
petit peu plus flou
ça ça peut jouer ça ce choix se le fait
de dire clairement ce sera Laurent
Wauquiez en 2009
effectivement ça peut ça peut peser dans
la balance les électeurs
des adhérents bien sûr ça peut c'est
très clair là alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est si Xavier Bertrand a
un ralliement franc pour
pour est-ce que ça voudra dire que Bruno
retaillod les estime qu'il est en
posture pour en situation pour devenir
le candidat ça sera intéressant c'est
intéressant de voir si ça se fait par
procuration
je pense que le soutien peut me tromper
mais je pense que le soutien un soutien
affiché de Xavier Bertrand je pense pas
que Bruno Retailleau le cherche
particulièrement dans la mesure où vous
avez Bertrand alors certes il est revenu
chez LR mais c'est quand même l'homme
qui est parti à la suite de l'élection
de Laurent Wauquiez en 2017 à la tête du
à la tête de LR
c'est c'est celui qui appelle qui a fini
4e à la primaire de 2021 donc je pense
pas qu'il le cherche particulièrement
quant à Laurent Wauquiez
est-ce qu'il a fait le comment dire
est-ce que la promesse de faire désigner
Laurent Wauquiez dès 2023 même si Éric
Ciotti au fur et à mesure de la campagne
était plus flou sur le sur le calendrier
de le faire à doubler vite pour la
présidentielle de 2027 est-ce que ça a
marché à plein pour le premier tour ça
personne n'est en mesure de le dire je
peux simplement dire que certains autour
de d'érections s'attendait à ce que ça
cette promesse là
soit en capacité de le faire gagner
presque dès le premier tour et le fait
qu'il ne l'emporte pas d'être premier
tour malgré cette promesse là fait que
bon bah voilà est-ce que Laurent
Wauquiez si populaire que ça chez chez
les adhérents bon bah ça reste peut-être
approuvé mais de toute façon la question
se sera même enfin sera pas du tout
celle-là sera est-ce que Laurent
Wauquiez sera même en capacité de faire
un score une campagne
efficace en 2027 étant donné que
l'explosion du jeu à droite et au centre
droit Alex a cherché les différences sur
la ligne entre entre Bruno Retailleau ça
va se jouer sur quoi pour vous c'est
entre deux touristes sur la ligne ou sur
la personnalité
c'est l'histoire de copie d'un âge tout
ça c'est c'est la personnalité c'est la
proximité géographique aussi on en a
beaucoup parlé on en a beaucoup parlé
d'ailleurs depuis hier soir mais bon ils
sont ils sont marqués géographiquement
il y en a un qui est très implanté
sur chacun très bien planté dans leur
territoire la Vendée les Alpes-Maritimes
ce qui s'est passé en Île-de-France que
la première fédération voilà c'est c'est
tout ça qui est intéressant enfin c'est
tout ça qui va compter c'est la
proximité géographique les copinages les
promesses faites aux uns et aux autres à
telle fédération ou a-t-elle fédération
beaucoup plus que les les engagements
programmatiques c'est intéressant de les
devoir les scores maintenant et de voir
ce face à face à l'aune du débat qui
s'est qui a eu lieu sur c'est quand même
un segment assez réduit de la droite ça
ça saute aux yeux en un an alors c'est
pas du tout que pour ne pas louer les
mérites des de là ou de l'autre ce sont
deux fortes personnalités très
intelligentes très ce sont des gros
bosseurs
ils ont un chacun un logiciel mais
il y a un an le spectre que couvrait LR
à travers ces cinq candidats à la
primaire de la primaire présidentielle
tu es quand même plus large que ce à
quoi on avait à quoi on se avait quoi on
se retrouve aujourd'hui une droite quand
même oui effectivement conservatrice
mais les deux signes droite dur sur sur
le régalien sur le sécurité sur le la
politique migratoire ce sont des
personnalités qui jadis aurait
représenté plutôt des courants de leur
camp respectifs et non pas leur camp en
entièreté donc ça c'est quand même un
une évolution assez intéressante de ces
dernières années pour la droite
c'est une élection interne ça
n'intéresse pas le pays hier Bruno
Retailleau dans son discours il a dit ce
qui va se jouer dimanche prochain
dépasse de très loin l'avenir de notre
partie ça concerne l'avenir de notre
pays vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça
mais oui parce que ce sont des acteurs
de la vie politique française évidemment
je vais vous dire une chose là ce qui
joue c'est est-ce que le parti des
républicains survit ou disparaît c'est
ça qu'ils sont en train de jouer là si
ils arrivent pas à avoir une belle
élection et puis à convaincre au-delà de
justement de leur club de femmes ils
vont disparaître ils sont quand même
coincés entre Macron et Le Pen quoi
qu'ils disent
soit le gagnant quelle que soit le
gagnant après c'est il va falloir qu'il
soit extrêmement habile et l'un ou l'un
ou l'autre pour essayer de faire revivre
cette maison
pour faire en sorte qu'elle soit je
dirais au rendez-vous de 2027 avec
beaucoup de capacités elle a eu une à
saisir parce que le Président de la
République sortant n'aura pas la
possibilité de se représenter que la
succession de celui-ci va être va donner
lieu à une bagarre absolument intense
entre ces potentiels successeurs et que
là et bien la droite les républicains
peut-être un coup à jouer mais bon il
faut pas qu'il se loupe et on va voir
c'est ça l'enjeu là aujourd'hui ça va
être très très compliqué pour eux parce
que comment quand on est LR et quand on
voit à quel point LR s'est réduit en
l'espace de 5 ans depuis les 20% de de
Fillon en 2017 comment est-ce que LR
fait pour s'adresser à la fois aux
électeurs de droite modérées centre
droit orléanis on aurait dit naguère qui
seront massivement voté pour Emmanuel
Macron qui sont plutôt progressistes sur
les questions de société qui sont pas
pour une droite dure sur les questions
migratoires mais qui veut demande quand
même un peu de fermeté c'est un biotope
un peu particulier et comment reparler à
l'électorat populaire
qui vote massivement pour Marine Le Pen
c'est comment faire pour réunir encore
de portions de ces de ces segments là
qui sont très larges pour les autour
d'un seul d'une seule et même
candidature c'est ça va être très très
difficile pour eux et puis c'est très
bien de penser à 2027 mais l'avenir du
pays il joue aussi dans ce quinquennat
donc il y a la question c'est que font
les républicains face aux réformes
d'emmanuels ils sont dans une opposition
frontale comme et bien les candidats à
la présidente du parti le Cloud mais en
réalité on voit bien que et bien au
Parlement sur certains réformes sur la
hausse des moyens des forces de l'ordre
la droite est présente pour la beauté la
réforme des retraites elle devrait
semblablement également la beauté voilà
il y a toute une série de réformes où la
droite doit être au rendez-vous et
finalement on construire co-construire
avec Emmanuel Macron même si elle a du
mal à l'accepter ça va être un premier
piège politique cette réforme de
retraite pour le nouveau président des
républicains
c'est pas un piège politique ils sont
obligés de la voter quoi qu'il arrive il
a vote pas ça veut dire quoi donc c'est
là où d'ailleurs Sarkozy n'est pas
complètement tort non plus compte tenu
de la non représentation du président
sortant en 2027
il pourrait très bien avoir un accord de
gouvernement jusqu'en
2025 enfin moi je le crois pas mais
ça se conçoit je dirais ça se conçoit
mais si la droite quelle qu'elle soit
que ça soit Retailleau ou cioti ne vote
pas la réforme des retraites à condition
évidemment ça soit une réforme qui
recule l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'est incompréhensible alors là il se
tire une balle dans le pied il
disparaisse de toute façon les deux
l'ont annoncé dans le débat sur sur LCI
Erik sotti comme rue de Retailleau alors
c'est Aurélien pradique
qui pouvait se permettre de dire j'ai je
j'entonne ma petite musique et puis au
Parlement on va voir ce qu'on va voir et
puis moi avec mes quelques députés avec
les quelques députés qui sont proches de
moi si enfin une réforme des retraites
qui
un recul de l'âge légal de départ je ne
la voterai pas mais ça voilà c'est à peu
de frais qui fait cette annonce en
revanche les deux ont expliqué que s'il
y a déjà 64 65 ans il y a pas de raison
qu'on ne vote pas bah oui tu parles ils
demandent ça depuis des années des
années c'était dans le programme de
Fillon voilà toute une série de raisons
il serait totalement illogique qu'il ne
la vote pas effectivement un accord de
gouvernement leur aurait permis on
accord parlementaire leur a permis de
poser leurs conditions pour qu'ils
accordent leur vote à plusieurs réformes
successives de de d'Emmanuel Macron et
organiser un peu ce processus là
jusqu'aux européennes mais bon ça n'a
pas été le cas pour en tout cas pour
l'instant et ensuite cette campagne
d'entre-deux tours le second tour c'est
de samedi 18h à dimanche 18h on suivra
tout ça toute la semaine on va pas
[Musique]